[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
as russia escalates its showdown with
europe and cuts off gas supplies to
poland and bulgaria what next for
germany
acrid smoke blankets delhi as a record
shattering heatwave smothers india
a face mask for cows and aerodynamic
seed pods will bring you the latest in
high impact climate solutions
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world we hear
from the people being hit hardest by
those changes and report on the race for
solutions
now europe's relationship with russia
moved into a new and critical phase
today as russian energy giant gazprom
cut off gas supplies to poland and
bulgaria both are heavily dependent on
their eastern neighbour for energy but
refused to pay in rubles as russia has
requested we'll have more details on
precisely how much europe depends on
russia for its energy a little later but
both poland and bulgaria reacted angrily
saying the russians had breached their
contracts
the suspension of gazprom's gas is a
gross violation of their contract and
blackmail by using a non-contractual
plan to pay in rubles through third
parties which does not guarantee neither
the supplies nor the bulgarians money we
will not succumb to such a racket
well the eu has also described russia's
actions as blackmail and a provocation
and the eu commission president
confirmed there is a plan to fully wean
the continent off russian fossil fuels
we've been working since months to
reduce this dependency it pays off now
we have reduced already the flow of gas
coming from russia
and with the plans i've just displayed
we will be able to get independent of
russian fossil fuels much faster and
this is for good and forever
now germany is europe's most heavily
industrialized country and as such
imported more than 50 percent of its gas
from russia in 2021 which places it in a
very awkward position our climate
correspondent hannah thomas peter is in
berlin
the energy crisis is of course having an
impact well beyond the issues of oil and
gas
amongst many western nations there's
real concern that globally countries are
turning away from or de-prioritizing
their climate change commitments as they
focus on securing energy supplies and
even within germany that is the case the
truth is it doesn't have a nuclear
infrastructure or program to plug any
gap left by russian oil and gas
it is turning to nations like qatar and
others to find
more gas potentially locking in a fossil
fuel infrastructure for the years to
come that it had said it hoped it would
would never need and it hasn't ruled out
burning more coal to create more power
so that people can heat their homes and
do other things
the practical reality of the effects of
what russia is doing is being felt in
even the richest most powerful nations
and germany is no exception
well let's look in some more detail now
on how russian gas supplies go into
europe here's our economics and data
editor ed conway
let's start by reminding ourselves where
europe gets its gas from at the moment
and you can see there's one place that
sticks out it's russia ahead of norway
algeria and netherlands it's an enormous
reliance and when you take that bar and
break it down to the countries where
that gas is received again there's
another one that sticks out let me put
these side by side so you can see that
germany is by far away the biggest
recipient
of russian gas followed by italy turkey
netherlands and the rest within this
others that's where poland and bulgaria
are to be found and what's happened here
ultimately is this at the moment the
payments for that gas that's coming in
go in euros back to russia and russia
has said no we'd rather have it in
rubles that's a symbol for rubles and
both of these countries have said no
thanks and as a result gas prices these
are wholesale gas prices in the
netherlands they've gone up quite
sharply that's up by about 20 although
it's come down a little bit although you
can see in the scheme of things you know
it has been a lot higher in previous uh
weeks but why has it come down why are
people not quite as concerned about it
well it partly is down to charts like
this this shows you uh polish gas
storage so over the last few years how
much gas there is in storage it goes
down during the winter and then gets
built up over the summer and the autumn
and just look at what's happened
recently uh with poland up very high
it's almost like they knew something was
coming so they've got a lot of gas in
storage uh in poland also consider
what's going on with these pipelines
it's mostly pipelines bringing the gas
from russia into europe and when you
look at those pipelines well poland is
building new lng terminals liquefied
natural gas to bring in the gas via its
coastline whereas uh in bulgaria they
have a new pipeline that's potentially
coming in from greece and that's
bringing in gas from azerbaijan so they
both have alternatives in the future but
if we look at these pipelines in
particular let's focus on two of them so
nordstrom that's the pipe that goes into
germany directly into germany yamaha
europe it's a series of pipelines that
goes through to poland so that's the one
for poland yamal and look at how much
gas there's been recently into that
yamaha pipeline in recent months it's
been really low so it's not like this
changes all that much for poland but
nordstrom the the pipeline that goes
into germany just look at how much gas
has been flowing through that which
brings us back to where we started
really it's all about germany it's about
italy it's about turkey it's about these
countries and whether they want to pay
in rubles rather than euros it is going
to be a very interesting next few weeks
well let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and an extraordinary
heatwave has been blamed for causing a
fire at a massive landfill in new delhi
blanketing the city in smoke the fire
which has been burning since tuesday is
adding more toxic smoke to a city that's
already plagued by life-threatening
pollution
india suffered the hottest march in over
a century and there are warnings of
record temperatures over the next few
days
now 220 million pounds worth of russian
oil has arrived in britain via tankers
since the start of the war in ukraine
the uk government has banned
russian-operated ships from docking in
uk ports but ships flying other flags
are allowed to import russian fossil
fuels greenpeace who carried out the
analysis say the ban on russian ships is
tokenistic
now more than one-fifth of reptile
species are threatened with extinction
that is according to a global assessment
of more than ten thousand species
published in nature crocodiles and
turtles are among the most at risk
species with more than half of those
assessed being under threat the report
authors warn that logging urban
development and invasive species are the
main threats to reptiles
and human-caused climate change will
make strong tropical cyclones twice as
frequent by 2050 that's according to new
research from the university of
southampton which predicts maximum wind
speeds in cyclones could increase by 20
percent these extreme weather events
could occur more often in places where
currently they are normally rare such as
cambodia laos and mozambique
now a face mask for cows aerodynamic
seed pods and capturing waste from our
tires three of the winners of the
inaugural terra carter design lab
competition it's aimed at discovering
low-cost high-impact climate solutions
rhiannon mills reports
the royal college of art a real
birthplace of the unusual now harnessing
all of that creative thinking to take on
some of the planet's most pressing
problems
it's something that prince charles has
wanted to encourage as he met the first
four teams getting 50 000 pounds each
from his terra carter design award
a mask for cows to cut methane one that
he could not miss and no all of that gas
does not come from where you think
more than 90 of the methane that
actually comes from the animal is
expelled from the nostrils of cattle and
that's why our product is so precisely
located uh to capture this methane on
top of the nostrils of the animal
there's also the team trying to capture
the waste from our tyres it's a it's a
huge problem it's one that we can't
think about trying to tackle fuel in our
own so it's always about reaching out to
the collaborators the likes of johnny
ive and his royal highness uh to work
out how we can actually bring this
product from a concept into fruition
and the iaskin twins art students now
working on how food waste like orange
peelings can spread seeds the idea is to
use aerodynamic farms that are dispersed
by the wind like it happens in nature
there is a few seeds like the maple
seeds
that use the helicopter like shape to
fall down on there
whether it's prince charles or prince
william there has been a shift recently
not just talking about the dangers of
what we're doing to our planet but also
making sure that these kind of
innovative ideas and getting the support
that they need to really make sure that
they go somewhere in the future
sir johnny ive the former chief designer
at apple is now mentoring the winners in
valuable support for the new innovators
whose ideas have never been more urgent
rihanna mills sky news in central london
well do stay with us coming up i'll be
joined by climate activist laura young
and michael jacobs professor of
political economy at the university of
sheffield we'll be discussing yes of
course fossil fuels and some more of
those climate solutions
[Music]
[Music]
look at that sheet of flakes and it's
moving this way
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
independent united kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians
the people in power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians impact all of us in our
everyday lives this is the worst thing
i've ever been through in my life people
turn up here with their child's stuff in
a black sack and just say i don't want
to and that is what it is it's
first-class poverty
is this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end
the real power
doesn't actually lie with the
politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news well let's get
straight into some of those climate
issues in the news today we've had the
climate activist lori young and michael
jacobs from the university of sheffield
a very good evening to both of you uh
michael coming to you first when we look
at the price effect of what happens when
russia cuts off bulgaria and poland from
its gas what would happen if russia cut
germany off
well i've been looking at a few of the
studies as you can imagine quite a lot
of economists including from the german
government have been looking at this
question and the study that uh seems to
me to have modeled this uh in a uh in a
pretty good way suggests that uh uh if
uh the germany has to import uh oil gas
and coal
from countries other than russia that
there will be price rises that will be
more expensive but the total hit to
german gdp would be less than one
percent um which equates to about
uh 80 to 120 euros so that's let's call
it uh a pound to a euro uh that kind of
sum of money per german citizen on
average obviously will depend on uh
different people's consumption so that's
not a huge hit but it's also not
something clearly which german
politicians
particularly want to inflict on german
citizens so this is why germany has
not yet decided to
boycott or abandon russian imports of
energy um despite the very much more uh
the urgent requests of uh president
zielinski and the ukrainian government
for them to do so yeah it's not quite as
united a front as the eu would have us
believe but it wouldn't just affect
german energy consumers would it it has
a wider effect michael
yes the imports
coming into europe from
russia particularly oil and gas go to
most european countries the uk is the
exception we have very little france has
very little because it has such a big
nuclear program but poland bulgaria
which today have been told that uh their
gas is being cut off by russia because
they uh are refusing to pay in rurals um
also import a lot so this is a a big
issue for european countries and it uh
it is the much more difficult issue than
supplying arms that is obviously very
expensive for the west to supply arms to
ukraine but the much more difficult
issue politically is the cost to
european citizens and businesses um of
uh of uh boycotting or abandoning
russian imports um the particular
problems will be on price it's there is
enough oil and coal and gas in the world
to supply those countries it's not like
there will be shortages at least not uh
there might be initially but it is a
price problem and obviously prices are
already very high and as you can imagine
if this were going on in the uk there
would be plenty of people saying well we
do support ukraine but not quite that
much yeah you don't want to bear that
cost and that is a difficult political
choice on that very point um will
consumers here end up wearing those
costs will they be happy to wear those
costs laura
they will and i don't think it's
necessarily a question of will they i
think we are already seeing people
having to take on those costs we are
seeing it here in the uk and we need to
look at this as a global issue and we
need to look out for our neighbors no
matter what country they're from and it
is regular everyday people that are
going to be feeling this cost taking the
brunt on and we're going to see more
countries having the same dilemmas that
we're having right now where some of the
poorest people are having to choose
between heating and eating and we are
going to see a global unintended
consequence and many of them for
people's health and for the environment
and so this is definitely something that
comes down to being a justice issue and
we need to have those empower
governments taking steps to take that
away from everyday people and to come up
with a plan that takes the brunt off of
everyday people when it comes to the
cost of this yeah well the cost push
through though i mean that there doesn't
seem to be much political will certainly
not in the uk
to impose a windfall tax on the energy
companies does that laura
no and actually michael and i were on
this very show in january discussing the
fact that a windfall tax is something
that could have been implemented and
could have taken a little bit of
pressure particularly we were talking
about in a uk context of some of the
people who are already being hit the
hardest you only need to go online to
hear the stories of how much people's
energy bills have already risen and that
is something that's going to keep
happening this year and although we're
going into summer months and people are
turning off their heating because it's
getting warmer it's going to be
something that we see and so the fact
that we are now however many months that
is three months on and it's still
something a windfall tax that should be
looked at and we need to be looking at
you know has anyone else in the world
done anything we did see that france
implemented a kind of hit to edf who are
the big energy company there and limited
the amount that energy bills could rise
to four percent and that was something
that happened at the same time we were
discussing a windfall tax we didn't go
down that route we are now seeing the
consequences of that but it's not too
late to still think about these
solutions and these are solutions that
need to come from the top down uh
michael talking about weaning themselves
off russian oil and gas is this going to
be a boost for investment in the
renewables market or will we simply see
it being replaced with fossil fuels from
elsewhere
in the very short term it probably will
be replaced by fossil fuels
there are other places to get oil and
gas
and in fact coal and germany and the
other european countries
that are going to have less russian
fewer russian imports will first go to
other fossil fuels but it will also
stimulate um more uh investment in
renewables i don't think there's any
question that
this crisis has has strengthened europe
europe's ambition to reduce its
emissions but people are seeing that the
climate impacts um uh are an important
part of the security issue that europe
now faces and of course it will also
encourage quite quickly i think energy
saving this is much the cheapest much
the quickest way uh of reducing
dependence on overseas energy supplies
and of course it saves money
to consumers and businesses so i think
there will be a big push on energy
efficiency uh uh insulating homes and
buildings and so on and also energy
storage of various kinds particularly
electricity storage which is a
developing technology so i think we will
see this as a moment when uh the move
which has already started to
shift the energy system in europe
towards renewables and energy saving is
accelerated and it's a terrible price
that we've had to pay or not us the
ukrainians have had to pay if that is
the case but it could be a silver lining
of the terrible circumstances that we're
now witnessing in that country okay well
let's shift gear somewhat
a face mask for cows well that is one
climate solution that i certainly didn't
see coming the science of course though
is serious methane from agriculture is
responsible for huge amounts of global
warming so what other low-cost
high-impact climate solutions should we
be looking at laura i'm going to come
first to you i mean once we stop
laughing about this notion of face masks
for cows you can actually see that there
is a lot of sense behind it can't you
can we am i allowed to roll my eyes i'm
not sure one of the things that i would
maybe like to bring up thinking about
cows and cattle and meat in particular
is one of the big things that we often
don't think about is food waste and some
statistics from rap who are a waste
organization actually shows that 240 000
tons of meat so kind of beef poultry
that sort of thing are actually wasted
which represents about 10 of what we buy
and food waste globally has a huge
footprint carbon footprint and that is
something that we could be tackling
instead of putting a face mask on a cow
which i think is a little bit
questionable and i think we should be
looking at lots of low hanging fruit
when it comes to climate solutions
reducing food waste getting rid of ghost
flights thinking about insulating homes
and buildings and really investing in
public transport all right well that's
certainly one suggestion where do you
see low hanging fruit michael
well uh i think that uh we should
methane is really critical but we should
be looking at the largest sources of it
cows are one so that's uh an interesting
development uh there uh gas flaring is
another one the oil and gas sector waste
a huge amount of methane uh by flaring
by that is by setting fire to waste uh
methane rather than capturing it um we
need to be capturing it better from
landfill sites around the world so there
are other places that methane can be
captured my particular kind of interest
in this has been sparked um or
interesting solutions in spark by an
idea that i read about recently called
enhanced rock weathering
a a difficult name but it basically
means uh sprinkling rock dust on
agricultural land to capture the carbon
that emerges from it and the reason why
i think this is so interesting is
because even though our primary method
of uh tackling climate change must be to
reduce the emissions we are so far
behind the timetable on doing that that
we will also need to find ways of
capturing carbon uh and storing it and
the great advantage of the idea of
sprinkling
rock dust over the land which can
capture that carbon is that it also
helps fertilize the soil
so we have waste rock dust which is
already accumulating
as a result of mining of rocks so this
is a resource which already exists and
is a current waste and we have a demand
for it
because it enhances soil fertility for
farmers so this seems to me to be a
really interesting uh potential solution
which could help carbon capture uh i
could also help farmers and get rid of a
waste that we otherwise don't really
know what to do with yeah a true win-win
solution there are clever ideas if only
we could be looking more for them
michael jacobs laura young thank you
very much as ever for your time
on the climate show well on the show
tomorrow we're going to be joined by
honorary fellow at oxford's
environmental change institute cece hugh
and richard black who's founder of the
energy and climate intelligence unit
but do stay with us because coming up
following unpleasant stories of sexism
misogyny and harassment sophie ridge
takes a look at the biggest political
stories of the week thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you